you
in the beginning there was only darkness
and endless expanse of emptiness that
stretched beyond the infinite
and then suddenly there was everything
you
following the incursions of all
realities the universe as we know it
stands as the eighth iteration of its
kind while we don't know much about the
first five what we do know is that the
60 universe was much similar to ours
within it resided the x-men the Avengers
the Fantastic Four and a myriad of
familiar entities in its why light of
its life the six universe gave way to a
be known as the dweller in darkness a
demon hailing from the dimension of ever
nigh the dweller a darkness sustained
and bolstered his powers by feeding on
the fear of living beings seeking to
recreate reality and be born anew as the
multiverses supreme ruler the dweller
and darkness fracture the m'kraan
crystal
which in turn would extinguish the
universe by pulling in the multiverse
and destroying its inhabitants while the
dweller and darkness was thwarted due to
the Phoenix force uniting the minds of
the universe's inhabitants and peace the
end of reality could not be stopped with
the radiation of the universe's
destruction permeating all existence a
space explorer named gallon of the
planet ah turned to his races knowledge
of Science and Technology and an effort
to both halt the spread of cosmic
radiation as well as prevent the end of
all things
failing to find a solution in the final
moments of the multiverse the sixth
universes version of Eternity merged
with Galan with the intention of being
born anew and a new multiverse as a
singular being of immense power
following this the cosmic egg of the
seventh multiverse brewed and stirred
amassing energy and gravity until it
reached critical mass and exploded
outward with a big bang
with its primitive universe consisting
of swells of energy the first form of
life to emerge for the cosmic entities
the chief among them being eternity and
infinity serving as twin concepts
eternity represented time and infinity
represented space and while the notions
of both time and space were relative to
the birth and eventual death of the
universe the power of these two beings
hailed from the very fabric of the
universe itself
following this eternity spawned a series
of child entities including empathy
eulogy expediency entropy epiphany
emnity and Aeon all of whom represented
aspects of life in addition to this
eternity and infinity were joined by
Lord chaos and master order representing
the opposing forces of absolute order
and absolute chaos in the universe death
represent in the end of life oblivion
representing the nothingness between the
collapse and rebirth of universes the
Phoenix force representing the total sum
of all psionic energy that currently has
ever and will ever exist as well as a
host of other entities each representing
one or more facets of the universe where
the various entities work to understand
their place in the cosmos the universe
itself continued to unfold giving way to
a multitude of races which fell and were
replaced and turn while some of these
races left behind single immortal
members who came together known as a
group called the elders of the universe
another race was emerging as the
technological superior of the universe
as the most advanced society at the time
the enigmatic race came to view
themselves as a guiding force for good
christening themselves the watchers and
helping other races to achieve greater
heights through technological
advancement but when one of the races
destroyed themselves with nuclear
weapons
the Watchers retreated from their role
as a guiding force who instead became
chroniclers of the universe as it
unfolded
during this time a race known as the
Celestials began to appear achieving an
extreme level of technology that allowed
the race to move beyond their original
forms taking on a higher level of
existence as clear states of energy
numbering in the billions at the height
of their population the Celestials were
met by an equally powerful foe named the
aspirants who viewed the Celestials as a
challenge to the dominance of all
existence engaging in a war that lasted
centuries where the aspirants decimated
the ranks of the Celestials using the
god-killer Armour the Celestials
eventually defeated the aspirants wiping
them from the universe entirely leaving
no sign of their existence or the
exception of records kept and passed
down through generations following this
Galan had remained in hibernation all
the while building a suit designed to
both contain as interviews as well as
regulate those energies to keep from
destroying him emerging several billion
years after the universe's formation
Galan was met with an uncontrollable
hunger for energy found only in planets
capable of supporting life setting his
sights on our Kyo Pia which was immersed
in civil war Galan destroyed the warring
fleet Singh consumed the planet going
forward as Galactus the Devourer of
worlds with the universe continuing to
unfold following its creation in the
formation of Galactus alongside the
cosmic entities the Celestials continued
their role as scientists and explorers
planting seeds inside of planets which
in turn would yield more Celestials the
role of Galactus became a force for
containment as much as it was
destruction and that his consumption of
life-sustaining planets ensured that the
Celestials population remained in check
and kept the race from overtaking the
universe during this time and around 3.5
billion years ago the earth began to
take form along with the concept of
pocket dimensions existing within the
main Marvel Universe pocket dimension
served as small sections of reality
accessible only through rifts within the
fabric of space-time
while these dimensions were largely
devoid of life the earth was taking
shape through the process of evolution
giving way to the Elder Gods who were
born to the finest magical energies this
time period also saw the rise of sublime
as a bacterial organism capable of
infecting other organisms around it and
bending them to its will bearing witness
to the evolution of Earth sublime wash
from the shadows as the Elder Gods began
consuming one another and transforming
into demons forcing the goddess Gaia who
represented nature to summon the
Demiurge the sentience of Earth and the
creator of the Elder Gods mating with
Gaia and being born in physical form
Demiurge began to consume all the Elder
Gods with the exception of cyttorak the
vishanti Mephisto Dormammu and a handful
of others who escaped a pocket
dimensions after which Demiurge
retreated and merged with the Sun
I'm doing what I enjoy doing it's like
other men like to play golf so they play
golf every chance they can so you don't
say to him how come you're playing golf
today you played last week was the same
with me to me it is such fun creating
characters writing stories
it's an exciting life and when you do
something that you know the fans seem to
enjoy that gives you such satisfaction
you don't want to stop
writing comes very easily to me
everything else in the world is tough
but writing I don't have any problem
with that I can't write fast enough to
keep up with what with the things I want
to say I think you never outgrow your
love of these stories of giants and
ogres and witches and all of that
superhero comics give you that